deux semaines après la légalisation du
cannabis
l'euphorie est passée et les failles
apparaissent à sa face même les
problèmes commencent à émerger
l'équipe de l'émission enquête révèle
que santé canada a octroyé des permis de
production à des entreprises où l'on
retrouve des personnes liées à des
membres du crime organisé
la nouvelle n'a pas tardé à faire réagir
les parlementaires il fallait faire ce
travail-là de recherches pour savoir qui
sont les investisseurs qui contrôle
réellement ces compagnies là parce que
ces gens là où il y en a ils enlèvent le
patch qui ont dans le dos ce matin un
veston cravate deviennent des hommes
d'affaires liste des drogues le premier
ministre du canada lui semble beaucoup
moins inquiet et concède du bout des
lèvres que des correctifs pourrait
s'avérer nécessaire
évidemment c'est un processus évidemment
il ya des d'autres étapes a à faire et
des améliorations toujours à faire mais
nous sommes très contents de la façon ça
commençait pourtant la grc affirme
qu'elle n'a pas les ressources et les
leviers nécessaires pour mener des
enquêtes approfondies pour savoir d'où
vient vraiment le financement
la ministre de la santé assure qu'elle
est à l'écouté est sûre vous dire que
les enquêtes ils sont menés à
grdf à travers centre est exaucé si
jamais que les policiers ne les fera pas
d'essai n'utilisent pas besoin pressant
c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose que
nous allons évaluer mais la ministre est
plus évasif sur l'idée d'interdire le
recours aux fiducie pour investir dans
l'industrie du cannabis des structures
parfois complexes et opaques qui rendent
presque impossible l'identification de
certains investisseurs
l'industrie du cannabis refusent d'être
la seule visée par ce genre
d'interdiction soulignant qu'elle fait
déjà l'objet d'une surveillance stricte
le gouvernement trudeau a beau répéter
que c'est pour freiner le crime organisé
qui l'a légalisé le cannabis
ces nouvelles révélations viennent
affaiblir cet argument et surtout donne
un nouvel angle d'attaqué à ses
adversaires politiques ici louis blouin
radio canada ottawa